physiquement d'abord ça serait un garçon
brun
matte de peau j'aime pas qu'ils soient
blanc un brun grand le plus grand mètre
80 mais 75 le la pommade le cheveux noir
j'aime bien les pommes la pommade
surtout les yeux se mettent également du
moment qui big louche pas
bien habillé style funky
nous prennent pas pour pour la femme de
service pour
qu'ils ne prennent pas seulement pour la
mère de ses enfants ce sera à moi de
faire la vaisselle jour ce sera à lui on
se partagera tout j'y vais pas rester
dans son fauteuil
qui est quand même le dessus sur moi
quelqu'un qui vous brûle un peu non non
qui s'éclate qui rigole qui aime la gai